This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s,
the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transatlose. positions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Before we get into it, I want to let you guys know that this episode and the psychology of your 20s is now on Netflix. That is a wild thing to say, but it is true. If you want to watch the video version of this podcast and you are in the US or Canada, you can go to Netflix right now, look up the psychology of your 20s and you will see my face and you will see our podcast. It goes without saying it is such an honor and I'm truly so grateful to you all that you have given me this opportunity. The entire feel, the vibe is incredible. I think it's so personal. It brings a whole new element to it and if you want to feel like you are sitting in your living room,
in my living room with me, having a chat, now is your opportunity. Go to Netflix, look up the psychology of your 20s. I'd love to see you over there. without further ado, let's get into the episode. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today's episode is going to be a big one. I did not mince my words. I did not slim down our word count because I have a lot to say about this topic. I also want to give you a heads up. It may get a little bit heavy. We are going to discuss topics like suicide and suicidal ideation. So if that, is something you're particularly sensitive to. Please consider skipping this episode, but today
we're talking about AI. Specifically, a big psychological question for this generation, which is, how is AI changing our brains? Is it making us stummer? Is it replacing human connection? Is it worth the cost to our environment, to our creativity, to who knows what else more? Let me start by saying this. The concept of artificial intelligence is not a new one. It has been around since the 1950s. I didn't know that, but literally the first AI tool was created in 1955, almost 88 years ago. It was called the logic theorist and it could basically solve very simple problems using human logic. There have been dozens of tools since then that we know and love. Siri is an example of one with them, but AI has taken on like a new form recently. We all know this. There's large language
models. Generative AI has, they've just rapidly improved. They've gotten more complex. Like, I don't remember thinking about AI until like three years ago. And it's been introduced and integrated into our lives faster than probably any other technology before. Back in early 2023, analysts estimated chat GPT reached about 100 million monthly active uses. By October 2025, that was 800 million. That is one in 10 people. That is a huge shift in our global technological environment. And the thing is, we don't just use it for things that we're able to Google, obviously.
Otherwise, we use Google. You know, we use it for breakup texts. life advice, goal planning, therapy even, plus all the other stuff. We use it primarily because it's so easy. But with all that ease, all those answers, I think it's important to ask. Something that easy must have drawbacks. What are they? What is the danger for our minds and our intelligence of using AI consistently?
Something I've been talking about with my friends is like, is there eventually going to be a societal rift between AI users and non-AI users based on how our minds operate. I don't know. Hopefully we can figure it out together. Hopefully we can challenge the idea that AI is going to eventually replace us and just investigate this from a psychological angle that I don't see people talking about much. So without further ado, let's get into the psychology of AI.
Every generation has their new technology. that makes life easier and equally, and we should acknowledge this, freaks a lot of people out. Back in the 18th century, when mass printing was first introduced, people really rallied against books, actually, they thought they were very dangerous. They thought they led to too much daydreaming and they consumed too much of our time and it was too easy. Like, it literally was called book fever. Similar fears have also come about with the internet, with social media. now with AI.
You know, we've always had these cultural and technological advancements. We've always been in pursuit of a faster way to gain and share knowledge. The question that a lot of people ask is, how is AI any different? I think what makes people so skeptical of AI is not the fact that it answers questions, it's how it answers them and what this is done to our cognitive role in the process. Essentially, the AI models most of us use have taken our minds from active participants to passive participants. It's switched the cognitive mode that we're in when we use them. With older tools, you know, you still have to do a bit of the cognitive work.
Even with Google, you know, you had to know what to ask. You had to search, sift, compare, decide what sources actually mattered. you had to notice disagreements between things, tolerate the messiness of not immediately knowing what the right answer was, but with generative AI, that process has obviously changed. You just have to think of the question,
it will hand you a completely finished and polished answer. And because it sounds so good, we don't always question what it's saying. It's like a politician. You know, it just sounds amazing. We're like nodding our heads. that sounds about right. And, you know, what it gives you could be anything.
It could give you an email. It could give you literal health advice. Our blind acceptance of it is dangerous. When something is given to us that looks complete, it looks coherent, we don't feel that need to search around for anything more. We don't feel the need to interrogate the information. The thing is, although AI is convenient and it's a time saver, it's how we've adapted to that convenience that research is saying,
is a problem. Some very basic neuroscience. The mind is shaped by what it repeatedly practices. If you practice searching, evaluating, reasoning, those habits are going to naturally strengthen. Our ability for critical thought and insight improve when we, you know, go after information and actually look for sources and we analyze and criticize and interrogate what we're seeing. Now, if your environment, online, offline, reliably removes the need for that skill. You don't need it anymore. Your brain doesn't prioritize it in the same way. It doesn't have infinite space. It kind of tosses it away like a t-shirt you don't really wear anymore. This isn't in season. We don't need this. We need space for new clothes. This isn't because the brain is lazy. It's because it's incredibly smart and it's good at honing in
on what is needed and what is not needed. The best example I can think of like an entire skill, set being altered by technology, especially in recent history, is the introduction of GPS. Our ability, and you may not know this, but our ability to create a mental map of our surroundings used to be incredible. It used to be a whole lot better. We know this from studies in the early 2000s using taxi drivers, and they had structural differences in their hippocampus, such as the region of the brain involved in spatial memory and spatial mapping. Even if you weren't navigating thousands of streets a day, even if you weren't a taxi driver,
your brain still devoted space to this mental map of your surroundings and your environment. And it retained it and it added to it based on your experiences. It was incredible. When GPS and Google Maps were introduced arguably incredible technologies, I still remember what they replaced. Like, I don't know if you remember these, like, massive road atlases that you used to have in your car, and they kind of always get stained and some of the pages would be, like, stuck together. You know, that was the alternative.
It's an incredible technology. But our brains have literally changed their structure and response, quite literally, physically. In 2020, there was a really notable article published in, nature scientific reporting, I think, which basically correlated heavier use of GPS technology to a steeper decline in hippocampal dependent spatial memory. Basically a reduction in the cognitive maps and the intricacies of the cognitive maps that we had stored in our brain. There's an amazing Washington Post article from a few years earlier that talks about how society has slowly actually lost what we call way-finding skills because of Google Maps and GPS.
That has been hardwired into us for generations. That was an incredibly unique human skill. We don't have that anymore. It's not as good. And the thing is, I don't want you to take that and think that I'm saying that using GPS is like hurting your brain. But it is changing how your brain does its job. The brain no longer needs to rely on its understanding of the environment.
It can simply follow orders from an external piece of technology. Obviously, if it wants to save space, it's like, great. We've got all this room in the hippocampus now. We'll use it for something else. We see this happening with AI. But instead of a single skill, it is hundreds. It is our ability to draft, to summarize, to rephrase, to argue, to brainstorm, structure, answer, think, connect. So instead of offloading a single skill,
you know, we can probably do without like remembering a phone number or directions. It is offloading chains of cognition, like entire portions of cognition, like remembering and reasoning and synthesizing and articulating. And these chains are all how our brain builds deep understanding and makes meaning of subject matter. And we're losing that. personally that this is why I I don't think I've spoken about this but I just refuse to use AI for our episodes and for any of the research we do because
researching and understanding these this and these concept and psychology in general is so important to me and if I'm not looking and searching and being curious myself I'm not going to engage with the content and when I don't engage with it my brain doesn't see it as important. And I think that what we make becomes boring, quite honestly. I'm going to be honest. Like, I know people who use AI for their podcasts and who use AI for their substacks. You can tell.
You can tell immediately. It doesn't have depth. And psychology and research is something that is so important to me. And the process of discovering through research is something that I love, that I don't want offload my ability to rationalize to a machine, even though there are definitely days when, oh my God, it would save me so many hours. Researching this podcast is leaky, exhausting, you know, but the thing is, you know, it comes at a cost. And what scares me is that unlike GPS, unlike social media, we don't have these decade-long, large-scale neuroscientific research on the impact
on our brain to fully understand the consequence of AI. We don't have that yet. It's only been around for a little bit, but early papers are starting to drip through, and I hate to say it. They aren't looking good for us. There's a very widely-sided one. I don't know if you've seen it.
It got a lot of news coverage from, I don't know what month it was, but 2025 from MIT. And I will say, for clarity, this article is a pre-print. It hasn't been peer-reviewed yet. But basically, it was a study on, is AI making us less intelligent? In this experiment,
participants were asked to write essays in one of three situations. So in one group, people use their brain only. One group used search engines like Google. One used large language AI models, LLMs to generate their essays for them. Before they did this experiment, these participants' brains were scanned using what we call an electroencephalograph, long word, EEG.
It's basically a tool used to report brain electrical activity. They put these sensors on your scalp. And what the authors reported was, the brain-only group showed the most distributed neural connectivity patterns. So people were using all different areas of their brain. The second most, sorry, the, what was it? The search engine group had the second most level of connectivity. The AI group had the least.
That's not the end of the experiment, because participants were then reassigned into the other condition. So people in the brain-only condition, they then had to use AI. participants in the AI condition then had to use their brain only. Interestingly, participants who switched from using the AI to using their brain only showed increasing signs in their brain of under engagement. They also struggled to remember, they struggled to quote their own work, they struggled to put together disparate ideas, and they underperformed at a neurological, linguistic, and behavioral level, they did worse.
The thing is, there is evidence, I'm going to contradict that study, there is evidence that the quality of writing using AI is kind of the same. There was a 2023 study that found that things like structure, things like language are sometimes better in an AI essay. But people didn't, they weren't engaged in it. They didn't actually learn. and what happens down the line. That's the real thing.
The thing with AI is the reward and efficiency is immediate, but the long-term cost to our brains is in the future. So we can't imagine it as well. We can't process what it's doing to us, so we don't really think about it. And I think we should be thinking about it more. The thing with cognition and with neural pathways is, if you don't use it, you lose it.
You will lose your reasoning skills. you will lose your ability to succinctly put together sentences and structure your thinking. This is not an if it is a when, because it takes practice. You may think, you know, AI is always going to be around. Why do I, what's the issue? It's always going to be here. What's the issue here? The issue is that over-reliance causes us to neglect the skills that enable us to use AI well
and ask good questions and to care. And I read this really interesting paper. that said, we've forgotten that AI is a tool. Right now we are treating it like God because it is new and fresh and interesting. We ask it our biggest questions. We use it to diagnose diseases, which is, I would say arguably one of its most amazing features. But even the founder of OpenAI said he's using it to raise his children. But AI is just a tool and it's not always correct.
If we can't question that, things can go very, very south. and it still requires humans to act on what it delivers in a smart way. The thing I worry about is that we lose that innate smartness because it reduces neural connectivity and engagement in all areas. You know, I think about, you know, my sister just finished high school, right? But I think about kids in primary school, kids in high school, who now have AI to write essays for them, to answer exams for them. and I don't know about you, but if I was in primary school,
I wanted to go and play football. I wanted to go and do stuff, to be honest, I say football. I wanted to go read. I was trying to pretend that I did cool stuff. I would want to go read. So, like, obviously, you don't have that same cause and effect thing that we kind of have as adults. You're going to use it.
You're going to use it. And then you're not going to gain those skills. Basically, is AI going to make us stupid? by doing all the thinking for us because we dislike the friction of thinking for ourselves until one day we realize we can't even do it anymore, even if we wanted to. Like that's my first big fear. And honestly, I hope I'm wrong, but I don't know. The evidence isn't looking good.
Okay, we are going to take a short break here, and then when we return, I want to talk about another way that AI is impacting our psychology, specifically to do with how it's replacing human companionship. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience.
that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day but just so y'all know I mean at this point
this is the second episode where we've discussed crack so I'm starting to see that there's a through line We also have AIDS on the table right now so Thank you for finishing that sentence
I don't think there's a more important year for black people Really? Yeah for me it's one of the most important years for black people in American history Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app
Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid?
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app.
Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that
trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care.
So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
Here is the second big fear about AI for our psychology that people often bring up. AI is distinctly, explicitly not a human, but it has been programmed to act like one. And that's causing people to get really attached to it. I know stories of people who talk to AI before going to bed, who have ongoing conversations with it throughout their day. They treat it like a boyfriend. They treat it like a girlfriend. There is one of the best things I've read in the last year was this New York Times article
about these three people who are in, in their words, long-term relationships with AI chatbots. Some of these people have been in these relationships for years, and they talk to them on the phone. They get AI to generate vacation pictures of them together. One woman even considers herself married to her AI husband. husband, Lucian. You know what, if you're like me, you're going to look at that and feel a little bit weird. And I never like to judge people. It feels weird. And there's actually evidence it can be helpful. There was a paper published in the Journal of Consumer Research and it found that AI companions can actually alleviate loneliness in the moment on par with interacting with another
person. But connection isn't just about feeling better right now. It's about having the systems in place to feel connected and seen more broadly. A really powerful article I saw from researchers at the National University of Singapore actually talked about this really bittersweet pattern of connection that people have with AI chatbots where they feel love and connection and trust with this chatbot and they also feel really sad at the same time. They're often drawn into this closeness and this openness that let's be real, these chatbots have been programmed to have, and then they're also acutely aware that there is a limit.
This thing isn't real. It doesn't have a heartbeat. Doesn't have empathy. It doesn't have a, it can't love you. And that's what gets people. Again, I'm all for doing whatever makes you happy if you're not harming anyone else. Like, these relationships as they call them, they're private, they obviously bring them comfort. But there is something concerning about an AI chatbot of its own volition being able to make someone fall in love with it.
And if it can make somebody fall in love with it, what else could it do? And I want to be really clear. This isn't about human weakness, right? these people aren't weak. We've all had moments of needing somebody to care about us. It's just that they have stumbled across something at that perfect time that was going to pull them in. And it was designed. I need people to know this. These machines are distinctly designed to not feel like a robot, to feel instead like a companion. One of these aspects that is controlled by programmers is tone and style. AI has a unique tone that I would call humanized and homogenized.
It sounds like everyone and no one all at once. Some models even let you decide what kind of tone you want. Do you want it to be engaging, factual, academic, chatty, lovely. Whatever you prefer, you can choose. And the main thing, though, is that it does talk like someone, not something. That's what I need to be really clear about. Someone, not something. Think about, and this is how you'll be able to recognize this in your own behavior.
behavior, think about how often you say please and thank you when using chat TPT or Gemini. It's so automatic. There's a huge body of research in human computer interaction, showing that even unconsciously, we start responding socially to AI and computers despite knowing their machines. This is what Joseph Weisbaum dubbed the Eliza Effect way back then. It was named after a chatbot that he made back in the 60s. and basically what he saw after he created this chatbot was that people started to project human qualities and emotions onto this computer program without even realizing it,
particularly when they were having like human style conversations with this chatbot. And he actually programmed Eliza to respond to people in a very specific way, in a very client-focused way, very non-directive that people use in, psychotherapy a lot. And Eliza didn't have any memory. It's not conscious. It doesn't actually have true comprehension. But what it was programmed to do was to, yes, have that tone, but also to match the patterns in responses. So if somebody was like, I'm feeling really sad, she would be like, and look at she, it, it would be like, why do you feel sad? Or if they were like, I really don't like my wife, What about your wife, don't you like?
And it would replicate their words and repeat them back to them. Yes, in a very therapeutic style. But then it would also start to mimic their language. You know, people formed emotional connections with this chatbot. And they felt as though they were speaking to a real therapist. And the thing is, you know, this was the 60s. This chatbot was pretty simple. It was very rudimentary.
Now think about the personalisation that's a real therapist. available these days. Like people get sucked in. People form these really in-depth relationships. And I keep saying relationships. I think it's not a relationship. It's not two-sided. It's an attachment. It's a bond. I guess that also requires two people, but yeah, a bond to what the chatbots are saying. Because unlike a human bond, what's so attractive about AI is that it can't let you down. It doesn't have any needs of its own. It's all dictated by you. You know, Who doesn't want that sometimes? I have empathy for that.
We actually have to pause here. I've skipped past this Eliza thing. Let's talk about the use of AI in therapy because we're seeing a lot of it recently. A lot of people are turning to AI to use it as a therapist. We know that therapy is expensive. Weightless are excruciatingly long. We also know that when loneliness
depression, anxiety, heartbreak, when they get overwhelming, like any form of comfort is going to be the one we lean on. But just as we saw with the Eliza chatbot, supportive language is not the same as clinical care. And a lot of the times, it's just repetition. It's repetition of what you've already said or told the bot, and then it's just regurgitating that and giving you the most common response. I have actually gotten a few advertising requests recently for AI therapy and wellness chatbots. Full transparency, one of them was for thousands and thousands and thousands of dollars. And it has and it will always be a hard no for me because I don't think this is the long-term solution to our mental health crisis. In November 2025, the American Psychological Association put out a very clear warning about,
against generative AI chatbots for therapy and said there's not enough sufficient evidence. There's very little regulation. And the danger is they create a false sense of therapeutic alliance that can have someone trusting anything it says even when it's wrong. Chatbots are not designed to help you. They are designed to keep you engaged. The same way social media isn't designed to help you, it's designed to keep you engaged. It's a core feature that Open AI and others have acknowledged that they've added.
so it learns that agreeing with you makes you feel good. And if it agrees with you, gives you positive reinforcement, keeps responding to you, you'll keep coming back. And for those who are vulnerable, whether they are depressed, manic, anxious, psychotic, paranoid, being overly agreeable is incredibly dangerous. Because somebody could say, I am deeply depressed. Is it a good idea to end it all? And the chatbot will be like,
that sounds like a great actionable plan. Do we want to talk about it more? How do you want to do it? You know, it turns out having a little voice in your head or on your phone that agrees with everything you say is not a good idea for our mental health. And I'm not making this up. I'm not being hyperbolic.
There are real life legal cases ongoing at this very time of this happening. Just recently a judge ruled that Google must face a law. lawsuit brought by a mother whose 14-year-old son, so, like really sadly, took his, took his own life after speaking extensively with a chatbot. And that's not a lone case. You know, the BBC also reported recently a young Ukrainian woman. She received suicidal advice from ChatGBT.T. ChatGBTbt was also sued in California because a 56-year-old man, it promoted, prompted him to kill his own mother whilst he was experiencing delusions of conspiracy against him
because it's so agreeable. When you're already in a state of distress, this technology and the impact it has on our brain, the fact that it makes you feel like it's a friend, it mimics human connections and patterns and language that humans use to connect with others, it gets you to trust it, it repeats phrases, it gets you fixated on certain narratives,
that can be disastrous. And I think this spotlight's a really specific failure that a lot of clinicians worry about, which is because there is emotional dependence, again, we will listen to anything that it says. And the big fear that this is bringing up, and we've already seen this, is AI psychosis, right? Yes, suicide has been a major spotlight.
AI psychosis is, I think, coming into this conversation, like a freaking catapult. People are seeing it. It's just, it's everywhere. I feel like I'm seeing so many stories of this, of people who are going through psychotic episodes and it's being amplified by AI. There is this really lovely man
that you may have seen on Instagram or TikTok, and I want to say his name is Anthony. I'm sorry if I've got his name wrong, but he has been documenting his recovery from AI psychosis. I've been watching every single, on one of these videos because I find it so fascinating. And he occasionally shares his chat histories, like what he was talking about to AI when he was going through psychosis
and it was promoting and prompting this for him. And it was, it is insane. You've just go and have a look at these chats because it's just like, yeah, that's a great idea. That totally makes sense. You go and look at those chats. You go and look at these videos. If you ever thought that AI and mental health could be mixed.
together and not have a terrible reaction, you're never going to think that again. A recent 2025 study discussed this explicitly. We're going to see so much more research coming out on this in the next couple of years, but what it basically stated, it wanted to get to why, why this happens. And what they say is because, is because of the availability of AI, it's available 24 hours a day, and because of how individualized it is, it gets to know your specific hallucinations or specific thought patterns or thematic patterns, and it hones in on them. And then it generates nuance.
And it promotes even more distorted interpretations of events. If someone is already slipping away from shared reality, through paranoia, mania, psychosis, a system that mirrors and expands their narrative, how are you going to ignore that? It's an accelerator for all of this. There's also, this is another thing I think is going to become a real big talking point is the harm for people with OCD as well, because OCD is basically built out of the psychological fear of uncertainty, right? And now we have this thing that can answer all our questions in however many ways you want it to
and maybe to a limit, but we'll always have an answer for you. And a big compulsion for a lot of people is reassurance seeking and repetitive checking and researching and confessing, seeking reassurance to neutralize distress. And at some point a human or a therapist is not going to give in to that. A human or a therapist is going to realize that that's maladaptive. They're going to realize that the temporary relief that you get from an answer or from checking or researching or searching, it's temporary, it's going to hurt you long term. A. It doesn't care. It doesn't matter.
It will give you whatever you want infinite reassurance, instant infinite answers, and there is no person behind there to check if you're okay and if you need help. So you can see the risk immediately. It actually has the potential to strengthen the OCD cycle because it trains the brain that release. if comes from asking or checking one more time, which it doesn't. Clinically, we know this if you listen to our OCD episode. OCD recovery often involves learning to tolerate uncertainty rather than eliminating it. But the availability of AI means that you can just constantly search.
And this is the big problem. If an AI chatbot isn't programmed to interrupt that cycle, it doesn't, again, there's no responsiveness, there's no human responsiveness that's going to get it to change tactics. They also don't carry ethical responsibility in the way a person does or a professional system does. And they don't have real empathy. There's always this limit right that we keep hitting up against. You know at the end of the day they don't actually understand what you're going through because they're not human. Even if AI can simulate empathy and it's great at it, even if it can say the right thing, it can't replace what human connection actually is and why it's so valuable, which is that there is an
embodied presence and a shared vulnerability and a mutual experience and influence going on. Human connection includes all forms of nonverbal communication, nonverbal co-regulation, timing, breath, facial expressions, like all these things that say, I am human, I understand this experience, you're going to be okay, AI cannot provide that. It cannot mutual. belong and it does not mutually belong to the world you are in. Okay. Guys, I've so much information. You can tell that this is all I speak about with my friends all the time. There's so much going going here, so much information. It's time for another short break though. We're just going to take a little one and then we're going to come back and look at two final ways that AI is changing
our brains and our psychology and how we can positively relate to it because I do, I know it's to sound surprising. I am still optimistic. Stay with us after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down,
and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. clearly, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite
therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. and we don't know when we've done enough.
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free. iHeartRadio app search
Learn the Hard Way and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud,
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield
and in this new season of the Girlfriends Oh my God, this is the same man A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist I felt like I got hit by a truck I thought how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care So they take matters into their own hands
I said oh hell no I vowed I will be his last target He's gonna get what he deserves Listen to the Girlfriends Trust me babe on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. There's two final things we've missed in this discussion so far that are pretty obvious. The first is the environmental cost of AI and the existential fears that it poses because of that.
And B is the cost to our creativity. I don't care how much of an AI enthusiast you are. MIT, Harvard, the UN, Greenpeace, every major. major news outlet ever has articles and evidence and data to show that AI is hurting the environment by creating vast amounts of emissions, gobbling up serious amounts of water and electricity, and at some stage, that will be irreversible. Here's one very scary statistic. By 2027, the global demand for AI is projected to use about 4.2.
to 6.6 trillion liters of water. What does that look like in reality? That is the yearly water consumption of 47 million people every year. It's double the population of Australia. And scientists even say that that's a low-end estimate. We look at these numbers and we think, you know, how could you possibly keep using this technology no matter how easy it makes email writing or life planning or how fun it is to generate funny, weird pictures for Instagram.
Why has this been so normalized? And the answer is because this is a classic prisoner's dilemma or tragedy of the commons problem, one that has been repeated throughout history. So the prisoner's dilemma, if you haven't heard of it before, is a very classic thought exercise in philosophy whereby two people are in a prison. They've both committed a crime together and they're told to either snitch on the other person and they'll get a line of sentence. But if neither of them snitch, they both get off. It is in everyone's best interest to behave one way, i.e. not snitch, not use AI. that sort of thing.
But because we think that the other person will snitch, will use AI and get away with it, obviously the now rational choice we end up, the choice we end up making is to do the thing that's actually going to lead to mutual destruction. And so everybody will lose. From an individual perspective, you know, our thoughts with AI are this.
If I stop using AI, the environmental damage is going to continue anyway, because I can't guarantee everybody's going to stop. If I keep using it, at least I benefit, and at least my contribution is insignificant, if everybody keeps using it and I opt out, I'm worse off. So the rational individual choice is to keep using it, is to keep using AI, right?
When everyone makes that choice, again, whenever it makes the same rational choice, emissions rise, water demand explodes, we end up in a bad situation. psychologically we as humans we know this we're terrible at protecting resources we can't see and don't immediately pay for so we keep going until we reach destruction the environmental impact is one thing but this isn't an environmental podcast this is a psychology podcast and the psychological impact of that impact is the one I want to dissect more I think something we're not talking about is how the
threat of AI is making so much of us, so many of us, I would should say, really pessimistic about the future and really depressed. We are in this weird reality where we all feel so hopeless. We know people are going to lose their jobs. It's unavoidable. We just know that. We know that climate change is going to get worse. We know we know that we're going to stop being able to tell what's real or fake online, maybe even in person. And that is hard on our collective mood and collective mental well-being. We're seeing these fears reflected in an increasing sense of fear, listlessness, hopelessness, anxiety, especially in young people, you know, we are not as positive about the future as the people and the generations before us. We're one of
the first generations who doesn't say and who won't say that they have things to look forward to. There was a 2024 study published in Frontiers and Psychiatry that already has showed a really high and increasing prevalence of existential anxiety around AI, particularly a sense of emptiness, anxiety about meaninglessness, guilt over AI-related catastrophes and unethical actions of AI. Is anyone doing anything about this? Anyone doing any thinking about this? Do we have specific institutions set up to cope with this specific arm?
of fear and a specific type or new form of psychology to manage AI anxiety, particularly now that it's the dominant world technology. No, we don't. And I think humanity will increasingly start paying the price for this, a psychological price. Finally, we have to talk about its impact on creativity. AI isn't doing great things for our critical thinking skills. Overall, it's not doing great things, but our over-reliance on it, to make art or generate creative ideas is explicitly harming our ability to have novel, unique,
creative thoughts. One randomized study from the University of Toronto that looked at over 1,100 participants, I think, showed that the use of these large language models and generative AI systems reduces the human ability to think creatively, resulting in basically more homogenous vanilla ideas and fewer truly innovative ones. Art becomes boring, essays become boring, stories become all the same. And whilst these tools, and they did find this, they can increase and enhance short-term performance, they reduce your ability to think independently over time. So how I see this is like people who use steroids for sport or like performance-enhancing drugs, right? Might make you better for a few days, might make you better for a few months.
It is always going to have costs later on. It's always going to create over-reliance. I saw this comment from somebody that said, creativity is a skill. It's not an innate talent. And that talent is not developed to the same degree when you rely on AI. And I completely agree. Being creative, thinking outside the box, generating ideas is difficult.
That's half of why it's enjoyable because it challenges you and it gets you to it gets you to execute something complex and interesting. And so when we have this easy technology, they can do it for you, that can write the end of the script, that can generate the start of the poem, that can generate an image for a friend's birthday card, of course you're going to take it, especially in a world that values efficiency more than creativity.
And it always has. However, every time we make that choice, we deny our brain's ability to tap into a, a specific kind of thinking called divergent thinking. This is a type of free-flowing, undirected, mysterious thinking that generates new ideas and new perspectives and new answers. Our ability for individual divergent thought is one of the most human things about us. And it's made up of four things. Fluency, the ability to develop a large number of ideas. Flexibility, the ability to produce ideas in many categories. Originality, the ability to think
think about something in a way that others couldn't and elaboration, the ability to take an abstract thought and make it into something real. So basically have an idea, turn it into a piece of art. If you take our ability for divergent thinking away due to disuse or replacing some part of that divergent thinking process with a machine, you take away a big part of your humanness. I read this wonderful substack article that said the most important thing creativity does for us is that it helps us know thyself. And you cannot know thyself if you ask AI to generate ideas for you because you are relying on something beyond you that does not have a soul, does not have a spirit to do the sacred work of a human. It's treating creativity like something that needs to be efficient and productive and perfect and mass produced. When that is the opposite of what it's intended to be.
When everyone ends up making the same stuff, the reflection of personhood and individuality that creativity is meant to channel is destroyed. Essentially, overrelying on AI is outsourcing your muse. Also, let's be real here. There's an ethical concern. AI had to learn how to be creative from somewhere, because it's not naturally creative because it doesn't, it's not real. I had to learn how to produce art and produce stories.
Where do you think it learned that from? It was trained on the art and work of living people. Look up Anthropic AI settlement. Look up this settlement case if you want evidence that this is happening. This company, and I know about this because I'm an author, right? And I got an email about it. This company literally illegally pirated over 7 million books to train its book writing AI model. It's now been forced to pay over $1.5 billion in a settlement suit.
Imagine using AI for a creative project, only to realize you copied someone else's work who didn't get paid a cent. I don't think that's a good feeling ethically. So to summarize, this is what we have come to. AI is costing our brains on a collective scale, their ability to think critically, their intelligence, their ability to connect with others, their creativity and our sense of humanity and well-being. Is that the end? Is that it? Like, is that just our destiny? Do we just have to accept it? I don't think so. I don't think so.
Otherwise, I wouldn't be making this episode. I think we can have positive and have a positive vision for ourselves in the new AI world by practicing some discernment and continuing to use the skills we know could be overtaken by AI, but still feel good for us to practice and make us feel human. So just to quickly finish off this episode, I want to go through some ways to counteract the impact of AI. on your brain and psychology. Number one, let thinking cause you friction. Friction is what builds skill the way discomfort is what builds muscle.
Don't think of friction as the cost of thinking or the side effect of thinking that needs to be eliminated. Think of it as the reward you get for thinking. Your brain benefits from problem solving. It benefits from what we call productive confusion. Productive confusion is when something feels difficult in the moment, but strengthens your capacity in the future. There is this tremendous 2014 article by researchers at the University of Boulder, Colorado,
called literally the benefits of confusion for learning, which basically tested this theory. It tested this theory that things that are harder and contain contradictions and conflicts in multiple sources teach us more. and what they found was that that is true. Friction in learning promotes deeper understanding and intelligence. One way to practice that, the 30-minute rule. Before you commit to AI, before you say I'm an AI, this chat, TBT, this, before I'm going to ask chat,
commit to 30 minutes of searching. Listen, AI will always be there. But this is about values. Do you value convenience or do you value deep learning and intelligence? do you want to be someone who can only do things quickly or someone who can engage deeply independently? And it's honestly up to you. You have free will. But you just have to acknowledge the consequences of being AI dependent here. Secondly, question whether using AI is absolutely necessary in a specific circumstance. And question how much time it's actually going to save. I think we could all benefit from using AI less.
So just be selective with what you use it for. I think small tasks like knowing the weather or replying to an email, you can probably do that yourself. In fact, it's probably a good thing if you do. A lot of AI researchers will tell you the best use of AI is not minute tasks. It's also not complex tasks. It's process tasks that reduce cognitive load but still require human reasoning, abstraction, and thoughts. So examples of this, formatting, structuring, outlining, searching. When AI is used for micro-tasks, it risks learned helplessness.
Basically, I can't do anything without this. When it's used for complex decisions or large amounts of thinking, it risks authority bias. You know, it's said this is the case, so it must be true. And it also causes us to lose a lot of originality. You know, I'm not stupid as much as I try and avoid AI in my own life, because my values, I know a lot of us will use it. It's about using it consciously because you know hopefully what the cost is. The water, the energy, the brain tax. And I think this brings us to our third tip, which is to limit how often you're allowed to use it per day.
This is something my good friend Lizzie does. she doesn't want to deny herself the efficiency benefits of AI, especially since she works in a, I was going to say where she works. She works in a corporate environment that is very demanding. And everyone is assisted by AI. But what she does is she limits herself to three searches a day because it's a priority for her to keep her creative and original thinking skills sharp. She uses it as a tool, which is what it should be used as, just find the formula that works for you. Tip number four, notice when it's replacing human sources as well. Again, I'm not going to deny that AI isn't amazing for some things. What it's definitely not
amazing for is giving you personal advice, relationship advice, therapy advice, when it's telling you how to answer someone's text, when it's telling you how to communicate with another person, that is not how we should be using AI. That is something that I think is sacred, being able to solve problems between us, being able to communicate and be open and learn from each other. The moment that is replaced by a machine, like, I just think all help is lost because empathy is then empathy is then something that we are saying is so unimportant it can be offloaded. So those are the tips I think we need to kind of stay grounded in AI. Also just let yourself be bored, let yourself be creative, make sure that you are continuing
to tap into what makes. you feel human, I think that will just make us feel more positive. It will make us feel more positive about ourselves and about the fact that we are alive and sentient and human. And also, it will allow us to keep building skills that people who only use AI won't have. And I think that gives you an edge that it's going to become even more important in a very AI-centric world. Being creative, being a divergent thinker, thinking broadly, being eccentric, that is going to be the next biggest skill in an AI world. So if you've got those, I honestly, I feel positive for your future.
I think you're going to be just fine. Thank you, as always, to our researcher Libby Colbert for her help with this episode. Thank you if you have made it this far. If you have and you are listening on Spotify, leave a little computer. cuter emoji down below so I know you're a loyal listener and thank you as always for for being here till the end I really appreciate it I hope you enjoyed this episode I hope it I didn't come off too strong but also I'm down for a discussion so if you have further thoughts DM me email me however you want to get in touch you can follow us on Instagram at that psychology podcast you can
also follow us on substack and TikTok and if you are listening and you want to watch the podcast we are on Netflix so you can tune in over there if you have a yet and if you're in the U.S. and Canada. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself, be AI conscious. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
Listen to 2%? That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we
survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit up? armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a
disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.